okay so what's this amazing symbol pie
well pie if I can draw the circle
reasonably well is the ratio of the
circumference of the circle to its
diameter so that's what pi is and we all
know that it's 3.14159 mmm - and I'm
struggling I think it's I think it's a
very good test of geekiness I think if
you can only write pi down to six
significant figures you're not really
very much of a geek but if you can go
four or five beyond this this increases
your level of geekiness why is it
important well if you're making a
circular building it's pretty important
for knowing bricks
very many bricks you've got to use and
for all sorts of geometrical problems I
mean pi just doesn't come in for the
problem the circle it gives us the four
PI R squared gives us the surface area
of a sphere and 4/3 PI R cubed gives us
the volume of the sphere so those are
very useful numbers to know that when
we're doing problems in physics and
engineering in your normal work yeah how
often do you use oh I should think I use
it every day two or three times a day
probably yeah and so there are many
problems in physics and astronomy and so
on though in which we're dealing with
things like spheres so the proton for
example is about one of the smallest
spheres that we can measure to any level
of precision and understand we
understand it very well and it's charge
and the electric field lines come out of
it so we need to know the geometry of
the circle that encloses the surface of
of something like a proton and of course
the moon and the earth and the Sun most
of the planets to a good approximation
are also spheres and when we're doing
problems about with them atmospheric
problems and things like this again the
size of the sphere is really important
so it crops up in just about every
problem inside
I'm a physicist and it's mathematicians
who really been fascinated and work for
a long time on PI and thought about it
and I guess one of the things we learn
in school that to a reasonable
approximation reasonable approximation
this number is actually 22 upon 7 now it
doesn't give us the ratio of this
cumference to the diameter that
accurately but it's a pretty pretty good
approximation if you put that into a
calculator you can compare how it what
its value is to the to the precise value
of pi but mathematicians have been
fascinated at the prospect of trying to
express pi as a sum of integers or
fractions of integers and there are
various ways of doing this and I think
one of the most remarkable ones is this
that PI by 4 now pi is 3.14 so PI by 4
was a roundabout nor point 8 and it
turns out that PI by 4 can be written in
terms of an infinite series and I'll see
if I can get this right so it's 1 minus
1/3 plus 1/5 minus 1 cents plus 1/9 on
and on and on to infinity so we've got
an infinite series this infinite series
here is giving us this value of pi if we
go on for long enough adding more and
more terms we get the value of pi where
these numbers how can I remember this so
easily but I start off with 1 and I know
that 1 is bigger than PI by 4 so I'll
take off 1/3 and that's a that's an odd
integer but that makes the number too
small so I now add a 5th and then I'll
take off a cent and then I'll add
another 1 over an odd integer and so on
and I didn't infinitum now I brought
along a couple of other series I mean
there are there are other series that
people like Euler and so on have
developed and I think I can just
remember these as well but they take a
bit of time to write up this is another
rather beautiful series a PI squared
which is about 10 if you want to
calculate pi you can do this with PI
squared divided by 6 is given by 1 upon
the square of the first integer then 1
upon 2 squared plus 1 upon 3 square
again up to infinity so it's another one
these infinite series and this is
another one for pi by 2 where now
instead of adding an infinite series of
terms we take here a numerator which
goes on multi multiply forever so we got
two times two times four times four
times six times six in the numerator and
the denominators got denominators got 3
times 3 times 5 times 5 times 10 PI 7
and both of those are going on for
infinity and that gives you PI by 2
which is of course PI by 2 being the
angle of a right angle triangle so that
angle there of course is the famous PI
by 2